[Music]
with dignity and respect
committed to free speech centers and
training straight talking and direct we
may act eight each other and you thought
provoking provocative and controversial
[Music]
hello and welcome to the pledge this
week a university football team in
America visited the White House but
because of the government shutdown there
were no chefs around to provide them
with food so their big-hearted host one
Donald Trump God is even bigger wallet
and ordered in some fast food where
pizzas we have 300 hamburgers many many
french fries all of our favorite foods I
want to see what's here when we leave
because I don't think it's gonna be much
pledged we don't get provided with any
food but fortunately our own a big
hearted friend with a big wallet got
some cash out in some group for us took
in everybody yeah it's dry January we're
all on diets so that's why I argue on
leaders don't understand this Majid says
we all need to be a bit nicer nick is
razoring his eyebrows at a new advert
and Michelle says locking up the bad
guys is right however long it's full but
first it's Greg what a complete mess
what a cock-up what a total disaster
welcome to the world of tourism a and
the most incompetent government in my
lifetime it all started when Mrs May
triggered article 52 early with no
strategy leaving us with no negotiating
position with the EU she then lost her
majority in that fateful election and
instead of trying to bring a range of
views from all parties together to work
out a way of achieving a brexit which
could command a majority in parliament
she carried on as if nothing at
the result ridicule from Europe a bad
deal and a crushing defeat on Tuesday so
what happens now I suspect there our
majority of MPs willing to work out a
brexit of sorts but they don't support
her do they won't support it with a few
tweaks and they certainly were
countenance no deal it could turn out
that a second referendum is the only
answer
not that I'd like to predict the result
but when a prime minister is defeated on
such a serious issue he or she should
resign as David Cameron did or call a
general election as Jim Callaghan did in
1979 Mrs May should certainly go she got
us into this shambles and probably the
only certainty is that she won't be able
to get us out of it essentially because
I was going to challenge you actually
you say it's the worst government in
your lifetime I would say perhaps Jim
callaghan's of 19 it ended in 1979 was
was up there but let's focus on where we
find ourselves now and really this is
this is what should happen you're right
it was a crushing defeat it was an
historical defeat so we should probably
remind the viewers exactly what happened
let's go back to that moment the eyes to
the right 202 the nose to the left
432
[Applause]
you're absolutely right crushing
actually Greg I think it's quite a nice
where you can put it for worse and that
watch I will come to what should happen
because that's the focus of this
I honestly think what shouldn't happen
is doing it again if you allow that it's
been incredibly divisive if you allow
that there is chaos I just think it will
become even more divisive and even more
chaotic so I really don't see that I
interviewed Michael Portillo on my radio
show now I know he's a bit of a divisive
figure himself but he actually said
anybody who thinks they know what is
going to happen is either deluded or
drunk or probably both and he's probably
on to something there and at the moment
hopefully I'm neither but the
interesting thing and I'll now yield is
that on Sky News they had professor I
think it's Bogdan or who's like the
constitutional expert and do you realize
the default position of where we find
ourselves now is if they don't do a deal
of sorts it will be a no deal on March
the 29th so that is what we're moving
towards which I don't think serves
anybody so I would call on everyone
whether mr. Corbyn has anything to offer
I'm sure others have to say I really
think the Conservatives I think the hard
right the ERG whatever I think you have
to look at some form of Customs Union to
get us over the hurdle so we don't move
to a No Deal that's what I think should
happen
I've talked quite a lot of politicians
the last couple of days just nobody
knows what's gonna happen really
interesting I've never known the time
when they said at least of all mrs. mate
and because the thing is there has to be
a consensus for what's gonna happen next
and there won't be a consensus on
anything there won't be a consensus on
her on a Norway style option because
that involves paying money and having
free movement there will not be a
consensus on No Deal so the default
position and the position that is
written into UK law is that we leave
without a deal but I'll argue I i I've
been saying for a long time that I think
Tereza may should go and what I couldn't
believe when I saw that that the vote
the other night where she lost by 200
and the jury of children 30 I it she
still was saying afterwards to people at
her and her people were putting out that
even if this deal fails which it has she
would put a version of this deal to
Parliament again and they're thinking
now this invitation that she's given
everyone to come and talk is the rooms
because she hasn't listened to anyone in
the past why would she suddenly listen
to them now so here we were on this
situation with a woman
who she knows this deal is not gonna
work she knows the public won't wear it
it's like someone who keeps banging
their head against the same wall until
it bleeds and it keeps bleeding and she
won't change but it's not really about
the public is it's about Parliament now
yes I just wanted to comment on some few
things you said Greg and firstly to say
that she got us into this mess I'm not
quite sure she did I think David Cameron
called the referendum then Cameron I
think the calling of the referendum was
the culmination of perhaps 20 years of
buildup towards that point and I have
some sympathy for her though I've never
voted conservative in my life because
and it's one of the reasons why no other
Tory wants to take her position at this
current moment in time and that's
because there is quite frankly her hands
are tied there's not much she can do in
her situation and actually even the
leader of Her Majesty's opposition aka
Dominic grieve concedes that point
that's a look at what he said it's
absolutely right that her deal has been
rejected because across the house the
analysis of its failings has been
identical that's not the Prime
Minister's fault I'm afraid that's the
inherent consequence of brexit and the
negotiation that's followed we could
have had a different leader it would
still have led to the same outcome so
the reason I show you that is because
actually the point he makes at the
beginning there is that anyone in that
position would after date have had to
deal with the same poisoned chalice a
moment she didn't get a big majority of
the election well she could have known
you could have seen just around much
okay but let's make this pop because you
made the point she was she went in and
she didn't she didn't tell them what she
wanted she took what they offered she's
the worst negotiator in the world sure
could have got I'm not gonna dispute
that I think if she resigns there's no
one to replace her that's the point
right and the second point I'd like to
say on the main point is a a general
election won't solve the problem because
whoever comes will have this particular
problem to deal with and so really I
think it rests hinges on Corbin through
the actual blent to be the leader why I
say that is if he had a brexit stance
that was clear discernible
understandable he could lead this
country easily and he has the other
stance we don't know where he stands
Jew shoes who can use Australian
presenter who I think has very recently
hit the nail on the head with break surf
this brexit Fiasco what's about as bad
as gets one of the world's great
countries can't decide whether it's in
or out of the European Union whether it
accepts or rejects the Democratic vote
to leave and whether it can or it cannot
work out a credible way forward
this whole shambles shows what happens
when the people in charge don't believe
in what they are supposedly trying to do
and that clip by the way I continue it
was and to me she really does get to the
nuts and bolts of what's going on what
happens what should happen because we
all agree shambles yeah so what is going
to happen and what I wish yeah okay what
should happen I wish that I could come
with a one-line answer to that that
would be simple and easy and I just
don't think that there is one I think
obviously she's going to have to come
back with her plan B I think they're
voting on that on the 29th I think and I
just I don't plan B as next much is this
coming Monday she has she's not gonna
get any deals through Parliament this is
the problem because I don't think
there's any deal could be put on the
table yes I am saying we should
definitely go for WD but it is the legal
default for not sure it's made
technically wise it may not happen again
legally and cord into parliamentary
sovereignty so what's happened recently
with the Berko donít grieve agreement
understand but they've come to an
understanding that they will suspend
standing with a 14 and the Parliamentary
Standing Orders which will allow for
non-government motions to be heard
now what grieve plans to do is legally
legislatively bind Parliament which has
a majority support in Parliament to
block the default No Deal option on the
29th of March if he and yes Speaker of
the House succeed in that so what would
you do what happens if they do that that
means the EU doesn't have to give us
anything if we effectively in this
country block a No Deal why was the AU
capitulate and give us an
that's not my question but they will do
something you said before you said there
was no one to take her place yes there
is I think she is responsible for the
log jam I think if she wasn't there
someone different someone better could
be trouble I don't know whether any of
you guys saw Michael Gove speech I was
looking at him and thinking future
primary battles back to the point though
if they did do that ideal options from
the Parliament okay what would you want
to happen next I think what I think
should happen is we should leave the No
Deal talk about there's no because this
isn't my debate but parliamentarian
should not be allowed to hijack no no if
they were to block a No Deal option in
Parliament which is what it looks like
may happen with the griever Co
understanding what would your next best
option be to achieve what you want to
achieve with brexit well there is there
is no OP we're out of options then apart
from to remain an annex in the real
world life continues so if they do block
no do in Parliament what would you like
to see yes it's interesting you're
asking me when there's no one in
Parliament can actually sort that out
that and I can't give you the answer in
front of me but but but I can't give the
answer but what I would prefer if they
don't block a No Deal it's to just leave
I don't know whatever all I would
suggest in that situation in those
circumstances it's in brexit as
interests as well as in remain is like
me to back her deal if it is blocked in
Parliament I mean the only option left
to both brick sitters and remain is in
the last hope for both brick centers and
remain errs in the scenario I've just
painted would be to go back to the
people I'm asking you what else would be
possible if they drop a transferable
vote option can we just stop because
we're kind of loose the next abate and
it's gonna be a bad break that anyway so
you can get this buff